[Musique]
[Rires]
m
[Musique]
10 google quel est le meilleur
itinéraire pour aller au travail s'il te
plaît le meilleur itinéraire pour aller
au travail n'existe pas vous habitez en
région parisienne et tout est surchargé
vous devriez tout quitter pour vivre une
vie paisible dans le sud ouest mais le
petit bourgeois matérialiste que vous
êtes n'a pas les couilles de quitter son
cdi pour ensuite déménager donner du
sens à son existence
ok merci dans 100 m prenez à gauche en
direction de votre vie de merde bon ça
va j'ai compris
vous la porte ouvre la porte ouvre là de
l'autre côté je ne peux pas m'en
demander au
hockey les belles hausses et baisses
notoires à ces grosses traces de negra
victoire
[Musique]
shiloh
est quand même
[Musique]
un moment donné je vais me fâcher
avoir un faisceau
[Musique]
dans ce pays